وانا احييكم مشاهدينا من جديد يصير كتاب
الامير هاري الجديد سباير تشويقا وجدلا
كبيرين مع تسريب تفاصيل دقيقه وشخصيه عن
علاقته مع العائله الملكيه في الكتاب
ذكرها ريان والده كان يشعر بالغيره من
زوجته
زوجه الامير ويليام ولي العهد البريطاني
كما قال ان الامير ويليام او قطعه ارضا في
شجار دار بينهما كذلك بانه اخاه ويليام
توصل الى والدهم الملك تشارلز الا يتزوج
كميل التي اصبحت الان الملك القرينه
استطلاعات الراي اشاره لان كثيرا من
البريطانيين ضاقوا ذرعا به ميلودرام
العائله الملكه برمتها وان الكشف عن مزيد
من المفاجات لن يغير ارائهم سواء ان
المتعاطفه مع هاري وزوجته او تلك المنتقده
لهما تسريبات الكتاب تاتي في وقت يستعد في
هاري بس سلسله من المقابلات التلفزيونيه
من المتوقع ان تحمل المزيد من الانتقادات
للعائله
رغم حقيقه انا ويليام وانا طلبنا من
والدنا عدم الزواج بكمل فانه والدي مضى
رغم المراره والحزن اللذين شعرنا بهما مع
اغلاق الصفحه الاخرى من تاريخ والده
الاميره
بالمعركه في افغانستان وارتباكها لم افكر
فيها هؤلاء ال 25 من طالبان كشر كانوا
كقطع الشطرنج وقصيت من فوق الركعه
هناك هذا الموضوع مع ضيوف في نعمه لندن
احمد مصطفى الكاتب الصحفيين بلندن دائما
الصحفي الرسولين ايليا اهلا بك اهلا بكمين
واسم حالي ان ابدا مع جوزين اهلا بك يا
استاذه جوسلين في الواقع الكل في انتظار
هذه التصريحات الجديده للاميره هاري ما
الذي سيقوله بخلاف ما تبعناه في الوظائف
الاعلانيه نبقى في انتظار مفاجات اخرى
ولكن سؤال المطروح او العنوان العريس ما
الذي يريده هاري من العائله هو يقول اريد
عائله وليس مؤسسه ولكن ابسط عاقل يدرك بان
همم العائله المالكه هي مؤسسه في نهايه
الامر ولها رمزياتها همم فما الذي يريده
منها بضغطه في كل مره وبموره كمته لهذه
التصريحات وهذه الاسرار العائليه
نعم اعتقد بان الهدف الاول والاخير حاليا
وفي مرحله التي وصل اليها الامير هاري
وزوجته وقرارهما بالعيش في الولايات
المتحده هو جاني الاموال
وهناك الكثير يعني من الذين يتابعون هذا
الامر ويتبعون الامور الخاصه بالعائله
الملكيه لا يجدون بان هناك اي عيب في بيع
القصص او كتابه مذكرات وهذه ليست المره
الاولى يعني بدءا بالملك اجور الثامن في
عام
1951 يعني هذا الشيء ليس بشيء جديد ولكن
العائله الملكيه تفضل غير ذلك فهي عائله
محفظه جدا والانجليزي
ولا يحبون نشر الاقاويل
الملكيه واعتقد با السبب الذي دعا بالامير
هناك مسائل شخصيه لطرح الكتاب ولكن الهدف
الاهم والاكبر حاليا هو جاني الاموال هل
هو جوني الاموال استاذ احمد هل الهدف
الاساسي من هذه التصريحات هو الاسترزاق
الاموال
التي يتمتع بها افراد العائله لكن ليس فقط
ايضا بما ورد في الكتاب وهو في اغلبه همم
مثير للشفقه في الواقعه همم مقصود به ايضا
من العائله المالكي العائله المالكه تفضل
دائما ان تبقى مشاكلها طيب كتمان كما ان
يكنس القمامه تحت السجاده كانت الملكه
الراحله قادره على
مثل هذه المشاكل داخل على المالكه ولا
تتغير حول هذه الضجه التي تكون تحت
الاضواء لكن ما يفعله
هو بالتحديد همم النيل من صناعه العائله
حتى انا البعض اشار الى ظروف النفسيه قد
يكون يمر بها
عارف نعم ما تم الحديث عنه اظن هذا كان
يتعلق فيما ذكره بقتل الافغان والطريقه
التي ذكرها بها تشوه في الواقع صوره الجيش
البريطاني ولذلك خرج من يقولون انه ربما
يعاني من اثار همم حاله ما بعض الصدمه او
ما الى ذلك لكن الامير هاري بشكل عام هو
شخصيه مثيره للجدل حتى ايام ان كان طفلا
حتى قبل وفاه والدته كان دائما دائما
يتلقاه اخبار الصحف الصفراء همم يعني كل
ليله يكون به من كان
والمشاكل كثيره عكس اخيه همم
لكن همم الفتره الاخيره وحتى قبل صدور هذا
الكتاب اتهامات وفي همم ذلك البرنامج مع
اوباما 3 وغيره من تصريحات بان العائله
المالكه ااا لم ترد ان تكون زوجته جزء من
اسره منصور ايه بشكل عنصر يعني هو تعمل
عائله بالعنصريه في هذا الزجاجه لكن له لا
يخلو من حقيقه يعني هناك مشكله فعلا فعلا
بعيدا عن الاضواء تحاول ان تلملمها بشكل
او باخر من
مشاكل امين تشارلز ديانا مع عشيقته وقتها
التي اصبحت الملكه القريه الان كاميرا بوس
همم الى مشاكل
وفضائحه التي لم تنتهي بعد الى مشاكل
كثيره جدا كانت الملكه الي نزلت الثانيه
قادره على ان تحتوي هذا وهمم ولكن مثلا
العنصريه يعني قبل همم اسابيع قليله سيدنا
السيده الرئيسيه في القصر التي كانت الى
جانب الملكه اليزابيز كيف تعاملت بعنصريه
شديده مع مواطن بريطانيه بسبب يعني همم
طيب ولكن الى جانب هذه المواضيع همم يعني
الاستاذه جوسلين يقول بعضه وحضرتك منذ
قليل ذكرتي اا مثال لما جاء في تسريبات
الاميرات ورد مثلا الباص كذلك قارب بين
هذه التسريبات وتسريبات همم ديانا همم هل
تعتقدين بانه ال- ال- الوضع سيكون مشابه
بان هذه التسريبات او هذه التصريحات ستمر
مرور الكرام
ستعامل معها العائله الملكيه كما تعاملت
مع تصريحات سابقه او ان الوضع مختلف او ان
التجريح او ان التسريبات اخطر هذه المره
اعتقد يعني بحسب التاريخ اذا ما قرانا في
تاريخ العائله الملكه هذه ليست المره
الاولى التي تتعرض لها العائله لمشاكل
كبيره ولكن هذه المره اعتقد خاصه بان
شعبيه ملكه تشارلز همم كانت على مر السنين
بسبب علاقه
بكميله بارك بولز التي كانت عشقته منذ
البدايه منذ ان تزوج الاميره الراحله
ديانا فكانت يعني شخصيته مهتمه بعض الشيء
وهو يعمل جاهدا الان لان يطوجا ملكا في
غضون الاشهر القليله المقبله وان ينسى
الناس هذا الماضي لان الشعبيته كانت في
الماضي مهتزه ولكن الان وخاصه وبعد ان
تزوج من كامله اصبحت شعبيه تتغير وتتحسن
اعتقد بان هذه الضربه ضربه الكتاب لن تكون
قاضيه بالنسبه للعائله الملكه ولكن
ستدعي الاعضاء البارزين مثل او على راسهم
الملك تشارلز وولياء العهد الامير ويليام
بان يقوم بترتيبات جديده بان يتعاطى مع
الامور بطريقه جديده ومختلفه عن قبل
يعني هل تتوافق اولا مع ضيفتي بانه هذه
التصريحات لن تمس من هيبه العائله الملكيه
وانما ستعاطى معها ستكون هناك ترتيبات
جديده او بالعكس البعض يذهبوا همم
باعتقاده بانه هذه التصريحات السابقه
والمنتظره هي قادره على تشويه العائله
الملكيه يمكن ان تضرب برمزيه وصوره
العائله الملكيه وحتى ان تفقد هاري ما
تبقى له من همم يعني مثلا ان يسحبوا منه
اسم امير كما سحبه من السمو الملكي
ليس في ذلك مشكله هذا يمكن ان يحدث لان
نهاري من من الواضح انه يعمل على تدوير
نفسه الكتاب
يعني عرض بالخطا قبل موعد صدور بعده ايام
وحصلت سكاي نيوز ونسخه منه وعرضت كثير من
المقاطع اكثر مما هو في مقاطع الاعلان عنه
كلها في الواقع يعني تشير الى ان الامير
بالفعل يبدو شخص مطرب وانا ميجان ملك لها
دور كبير في مثل هذه التسريبات والتصريحات
والافشاء ل- اا امور شخصيه جدا لاتهم احد
في الواقع لكنها نعم تنال من العالم
العائله الملكه العائله تتصرف بالحكمه
التقليديه حتى الان وهو عدم الرد الا تعطي
الموضوع اكبر من حجمه همم بطريقه
العائله الملكيه ولكن هذه المراه هل تعتقد
بانها ستبقى على نفس هذا يعني
هي ستبقى في الواقع اتصور انه لن يكون لك
رد من راي مالكه حتى بعد صدور الكتاب لكن
المشكله ان لا همم ما يمكن ان يستمر هو
عارف دلوقتي المتحده اذا اذا لم يؤدي
الكتاب والمقابلات الى ما يرجونه همم
كلاهما فاظن انه ستكون هناك الكثير من
الارشات التي ربما تكون اكثر درهما ربما
الجزء المتعلق همم وهو في الواقع حقيقي
وهو من ال- مقاطع القليله ذات يعني تستحق
القراءه في الواقع هو حديث ساريا انه
واخيه همم يعني كاد ان يطلبها اعاده
التحقيق في مقتل والدته في همم حادثه
النفق في باريس ولكن القائمون على القصر
قرروا الا يفعل ذلك همم مثل هذه الامور قد
تعيد الاذان خاصه في وجود
ملكه الان ملكه قرينه هذا يمكن ان يضر
فعلا
لعائله المالكه بشكل خصا وان هناك تسريبات
اخرى تتعلق بكامله وانه واخيه كان يرفضان
ان يتزوجها والده وايضا انها كانت مسؤوله
عن تسريب الكثير من الامور الخاصه
بالعائله المالكه الى الصحافه هو تحدث حتى
اكثر من ذلك هو قال بانه هناك صفقه بين
العائله الملكيه وبين الصحافه عموما قال
بانه العائله الملكيه هي من تزود الصحافه
ببعض المعلومات وان رات بان صحافه تركز
على شخص والعائله الملكيه لا ترغب في ان
همم تظهر اسرار هذا الشخص فانا العائله
نفسها تمكن الصحافه من اسرار شخص ثاني حتى
تبعد الشبهه او حتى
اشار الى انه هو همم ظلم في هذا الموضوع
سيد احمد
فقط القصر وليست فقط العائله المالكه لكن
اصغر سياسي همم في اصغر تكوين في المؤسسه
يقوم بهذا وهو مساله التسربه والتسربه
المضاده همم هذا تلاعب بالصحافه لكن في
النهايه لن انسى ان القصر ما زال يلقي همم
بلائمه في همم تطور مشكله ديانا ادى الى
وفاتها على المقابله التي اجرتها مع بي بي
سي يعني ايضا همم القصر ليس دائما راضيا
عن الاعلام وهم يحدث الان من همم تغطيه
للكتاب وللمقابلات من هاري لا يردد قصره
الاطلاق
ستبقى هذه التصريحات ان كان هدف هاري
وميكان هو هدف همم مالي بالتحديد وكذلك
محاوله همم النيل من العائله
لسبب او لاخر همم الى متى
المحتمله ان لن تتدخل العائله طبعا في
اطار عدم حديثها او عدم شرح ما المنتظر
اعتقد بان الكتاب لن يكون
التعبير يعني عن ما يشعر به الامير
الاخير تقد يليه اشياء اخرى
فهناك معلومات تقول بان مكان هي ايضا بان
تنشر مذكراتها في العائله الملكه ايضا
وبيعتقاد الشخصي كل هذا يعني ليس لهما
الدور الدور الملكي كما كان همم قبل فهما
يعيشان حاليا في الولايات المتحده ولا
اعتقد بانه هناك همم سبل للعوده الى
العائله المالكه فهو قطع بيديه الجسر
وحطمه لا الرجوع الى العائله الملكه فقد
ربما يكون هناك فيلم سينمائي يوما ما ولكن
الصلاحيه قد تكون همم محدوده يعني
تصريحات النهائيه
صحيح قدم العديد من المعلومات ولهذا السبب
البعض يطرح سؤال نهايه هذه التصريحات هل
ستكون او سيكون لهذا المسلسل نهايه
انا اتفق مع ضيفك الكريم عندما قال بان
اذا ما قرانا همم بعض الاشياء التي ذكرت
في الكتاب همم كل شيء يدل على ان الامير
هاري همم مطرب نفسيا وهناك من يقول بان
اللوم يقع على من هم من حوله وعلى على
النصائح التي تقدم له ان كان من زوجته او
من غيرها وهذا السؤال الكبير الذي يطرح
نفسه يعني شخصيه بحجم الامير هاري
ومعلومات
يعني بهذه الطريقه لابد من ان يكون هناك
شخص مسؤول شخص يواجهه فهو قام ب- همم
بطريقه يعني غير مسبوقه وقدم معلومات
شخصيه وخاصه جدا ليس فقط على مستوى
العائله الملكه وعلى علاقه المطربه مع
اخيه مع والده وانما تدرى بذكر همم همم
يعني قصه لا تذكرها صحافه كثيرا في
بريطانيا ولكنها ذكرت في الماضي عندما قال
في كتابه بان ابيه الملكه تشارلز كان
يداعبه في يداعبه في بعض الاوقات ويمزح
معه ويقول انت قد تكون لست ابني الشرعي
يعني وبعد ذلك تكلم في الكتاب ايضا لان
النسخه الاسبانيه همم هي في الاسواق صحيح
نحن سنبقى صحيح نحن سنبقى في انتظار كتابه
المعنون
وكذلك سنبقى في انتظار همم لقاءاتها
التلفزيونيه همم غدا وفي انتظار التصريحات
ستكون المقابله الاولى الاولى طيب سنبقى
في انتظارها شكرا لكم
ستكون الامور مستقبلا سواء بالنسبه له او
بالنسبه للعائله الملكه بالندن الصحفيه
ومن لندن كذلك الاستاذ من مصطفى الكتبه
صحفي شكرا لكم